[Music]
welcome all right and we are live
I know podcast Lords gave me that net I
am Lord cogito and who is this fine
gentleman we have in the realm today
hello guys I'm Roderick I'm a producer
in answer studios and currently I'm
working on game day our cyberpunk
isometric narrative RPG now game deck
definitely caught my eye I see cyberpunk
I see an isometric RPG I said I need to
set up an appointment with these guys
okay so a lot of games are coming out
from polling studios you know a lot of
creative projects give us the whole
premise and idea behind game deck what's
the story do the people who don't have a
clue okay so game that is based on a
book series of Polish outdoor Martin
undream and it's a story about detective
to solving cases in virtual worlds so
you need to login into different games
in Warsaw city in 22nd century
awesome awesome so let's get right into
the game anyway with enough further ado
talk let's talk about it so if we got a
demo right now of game deck so let's see
some game playing what's going on him
and this game looks phenomenal your
style looks fantastic
currently in aurelio and Salo city it's
a it's like a slams of the worst of
security in 22nd century and we were
asked by our clients time to log in and
meet him in harvest time in order to do
so we're gonna have to use a coach
because that's how you're supposed to
login into games in the future straight
to the ball we go straight to the bar
about ourselves the bouncers examine us
yeah and she's giving us a hard time so
we can use our aspect which is our like
a character creation system we can just
try to talk our way through it or just
make a standard type of table top row on
charisma I'm gonna use aspect because
it's the most is the most safe solution
I'm gonna back you up because you
actually said a cool point now you said
that with charisma you can you can roll
different attributes for your character
how does that work to get what if I
wanted to get my charisma what would I
have to do yeah if you want to
like a crazier charisma you need to talk
a lot to the people and convince them
but there is no failed state in the game
so if you fail in a dialogue you for
example get a nice bonus because we are
all we are we sorry we all learn from
our failures right so there is no like a
wrong choice it's okay and yeah your
character will be built by your choices
in dialogues interaction interactions
based on how do you approach the
problems of the game - all right sounds
good
a very big
and this is an opportunity for me to
tell you a little bit more under how we
approach the design of the case every
single case in our game was first
prototype as tabletop RPG we have a game
master or a creative director marching
and we played multiple sessions for
example for harvest time and just write
down and record like what choices to
player make and for example for us it
was your going into the bar so let's get
your drink you drink oh baby so we're
gonna talk with bartender along they
have already it's necessary your game
yes I love this and because doc you
don't wanna let us see into coach if we
don't fake him or we can use an aspect
that we are esports esports Olivia yes
exactly any sport guys just play for
free so we're not gonna pay we're gonna
save this money for later
an ER we have we can that's pre alpha 3
alpha we're every now you said this was
initially based off a tabletop game also
not a game but like a session - actually
yeah we made a session because it's our
in-house system not some Dungeons &
Dragons and stuff so we found the bed
yeah and this one is ready this one is
working so we just enter her this time
and we have to find stun we can do it in
multiple ways we can ask someone to make
some investigation we can explore or we
can use for example minigame do
something for someone like silent side
quest now let me let me ask you a quick
question here for those who don't
understand the concept of harvest time
explain what's happening right now
okay so harvest time it's came inside of
a gay exactly it's a free-to-play game
so we are laughing a little bit on this
farm bill things with a progress bars or
a money counter here if you grind some
money actually you can do well what you
can do in the free-to-play games for
example you can grind some money and
spend it for a gap for again or or order
drink in a saloon and so on and so on
and so on as you can see there are
players yeah they're hardcore grinders
but so
making money and here's the stunt so
we're gonna ask him like what our job is
and he will tell us that something is
happening two players stand there and
different asset like a acident and there
they got some some pains sorry
and actually we unlocked information in
the action that they all have similar
symptoms okay and I'm gonna cover
deduction system in a second okay this
is our basic system to conclude the case
gotcha
we have a question that we want to find
out right now yep
we have clues to the left and we will
have some interpretation of the question
right here depending on players choice
there is no right and wrong choice okay
the different paths will unlock so the
different different characters will come
up different like interactions and so on
and so on maybe even you will log in in
two totally different games Wow
so again based on that whole if you pull
up that chart this can this could pass
out a bunch of different ways based on
the interactions oh yes
as you see it's
yes and it's gonna have even bigger for
some cases okay but right now we need to
find out the words going on with this
more grass so no we can
money lokah because they're experienced
some some frame so they can just find
out if we if you have the same passion
the people are complaining in the game
that while they're doing that they're
getting pay exactly AFL down is he
pledged okay there is some accident and
we can there's a lot of problems with
this game man
people that just pass it out we can do
this game bug I don't know if I want
login to this one yeah we can just try
to pack it and find out what's going on
we can make a role intelligence and it's
a success so we're gonna lock him safely
and now we know that they have some
accelerate coaches there right so it's
right here we can find out more
we can actually talk with people here
are you feeling this again yeah he's
feeling dizzy something is something's
wrong
so we can ask him about it
nothing happened but there are a lot of
people we can talk of Jeanette and
Jeanette will tell us that she Vegas
deals someone's for something from her
some painkillers
oh sorry actually it will be Bonita all
it's got to be later
yeah and she was robbed okay so right
now if we talk with her she will tell us
to talk to Chicago gotcha
but right here we can find out that
there is some skin on the on the fence
okay we can steal it and put it on and
we'll find out that the time is speed up
when we have a orange skin right now
it's not visible on the game the ground
it will be in the field final game in
the final bill will have its pre-alpha
right yeah that's exactly and we can
examine it
and yeah feels candy pills [ __ ] it's
candy
but
more so more investigation data it's
exactly when you look for clues to to
conclude the case okay and Marica have a
speech problem so it's another one so
would you describe game Dex gameplay
loop as investigations getting close to
get objectives are locked and the key is
that well you consider a lot of this of
the core game right loop yes exactly
it's about the whole game is about
interacting with people about
interrogating them like finding out
what's going on but also like a mini
systems inside specific for every every
case for example here you have those
this little free to play Mac mechanics
where and grind money but for a
different game it will be something for
example a combat or something totally
else
the game sounds good so it is different
genres of games wow that's pretty cool
yes but it's gonna be a lot because the
city is like a brief life of 22nd
century citizens it's similar to already
player 1 for example
okay okay a lot of your life inside
virtual words gotcha
yep nice okay we have the fourth clue of
the hand right now we can conclude the
case and for example say that someone
else is pulling the strings so we are
gonna uncover different paths in
deduction right
we can say that it's a bug or a feature
so the story will unfold in totally
different direction or we can just say
that the legend please we don't care we
don't give a damn about them and we just
we will just come back to Stan does Stan
okay give me my money I don't have I
don't want to have anything like yeah
yeah I will actually do it we can
explore a little more we can like change
our mind at this point that's not good
ask you what rather sold it guys so I'm
just gonna tell the junkies we're moving
on and he's he will stop doing drugs
I'll be fine but the kid will cause he
is a game coming
in a previous case and if we share with
him our conclusion from the conclusion
from the deduction yeah he will share
something with us he will give us
another key so we so we can change our
mind and explore a little bit more nice
he's gonna tell us about manage there is
upon that foundation Nanette is a is a
boss of the foundation and as you see we
can we have another information
deduction yet exactly an another
but choice between
in the net and maybe someone else was
the body guy in this case he's just for
another this is awesome and I like the
premise cyberpunk lotta investigation I
like the whole harvesting and you said
different games are coming right not
just a heart like we go that we're also
gonna get like you said there'll be some
combat maybe okay you can you hand us a
little other game genres we might get
not yet it's too soon to tell but we are
working on something huge and we are
coming to the Kickstarter very very soon
so stay tuned guys because it's gonna be
power soso game deck cooperative
Kickstarter steam initially and maybe
hopefully if things go right baby the
platform's if it's go right constantly
floated we're thinking about it alright
you heard it here first game deck a
little podcast dog using like that very
unique title with we're gonna be
following this very closely an absolute
pleasure thank you very much others to
wishlist and have a good one all right
you too
[Music]
you
[Music]